- I mean, how difficult was
it to keep working, though?
Like, 'cause it, I mean,
I've heard, I have people in my life
that I know that have MS,
but I've never experienced it personally,
so I never like to pretend
I know what that's like.
So, it's like, it has to be
wearing on you emotionally,
mentally, and physically.
How was that to keep working?
- Well, there's four
different kinds of MS.
So, not everyone is the same.
Everyone's symptoms are different.
Everyone's experience
with it is different.
Every day is different.
So that is just so that
people understand that.
'Cause people are like,
"Well, why aren't you like this one
and you're feeling better like this one?"
And it's like, everyone has a
different experience with it.
So that's just a preface.
Shooting the show was the
hardest thing I'd ever done
in my life, because I was
diagnosed during shooting.
And I didn't know what
was happening to me.
I couldn't walk.
They had to use a
wheelchair to get me to set.
I was freaking out until someone was like,
"You need an MRI."
And then I found out on a
Monday after work that I had MS,
you know, a disease that I'm gonna have
for the rest of my life.
And then I started thinking
about the last four years
and I had very small symptoms.
And I think that's important
for people, you know,
let's not all be hypochondriacs
and run to the doctor
when our leg gets weak, but-
- But be aware.
- That was happening
to me four years ago,
where we were on set and I'd go like,
"Ooh, I think I'm tired," you know?
So, it presented itself
like a few years ago
until it just got as bad as it did.
- That's hard, Christina, that's hard.
Like getting that call and being at work
and having that kinda news
like laid on you and ooh.
That's really hard.
- Can I say it sucked balls?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, you can
- Thank you.
- Say whatever the hell
you want. (laughing)